[Musique]
bonjour et les wiltord dorval bonjour
vous êtes candidat donc pour les
élections municipales et communautaires
à macouba et c'est votre troisième
candidature pourquoi avoir choisi de
tenter une nouvelle fois votre chance je
pense que eelv après une longue
réflexion de quatre cas mais je vu ce
qu'a fait l'équipe en place qui n'ont
pas respecté ce qu'ils avaient dit lors
de l'élection de 2014
et vu la situation économique et
financière de la commune j'ai dit que je
ne pouvais pas laisser une commune dont
je suis issue à l'agonie et donc lorsque
j'ai analysé les côtes de la commune
j'ai constaté qu'ils avaient un énorme
déficit bien que je suis au conseil
municipal
je suis au conseil municipal mais il y
avait des choses beaucoup de choses
cachées
donc j'ai découvert en lisant tout
l'écho recommandations de la cour des
comptes et j'ai trouvé que ma commune la
commune allait verve ce que j'appelle la
barque août avec un déficit énorme quel
que soit le code
le compte administratif quel que soit le
compte qu'on veut parler si le coût
d'investissement le compte de
fonctionnement
tout est négatif et c'est pas négatif à
la limite mais c'est le cas de beaucoup
de communes en martinique
c'est le cas de beaucoup de communes
mais les autres communes
lorsqu'on regarde le déficit qu'ils ont
en parallèle ils ont ils ont crié ils
ont mis en place des activités
ils ont mis en place des infrastructures
là on peut dire que il ya une
corrélation positive entre ce qu'ils ont
fait et ce qu'ils ont dépensé au macumba
les côtes sont négatives
mais on ne voit pas de création dont il
y a un problème et si ce problème si ce
problème que je veux je veux éclaircir
pour les mac ou bêta
dites moi alors qu'elle sera justement
votre priorité si vous êtes élu en mars
prochain maire de macumba si je suis
élue en mars prochain
la commune a une dette colossale que
dois-je faire je fais un audit
je fais un audit sur les comptes l'audit
me diras les causes de cette dépense et
je suivrai les commanderies ou encore la
dation pardon des techniciens qui
m'entourent et des techniciens je veux
dire des finances et aussi ceux de
l'audit
s'il y a des poursuites il ya des
détournements ou autres jeux main je
m'orienterais vers le juridique
ensuite je me dis qu en place un pain
avec mon conseil municipal au plan de
redressement de la commune
parce que faut pas oublier dans cette
commune c'est une commune
on peut dire d'ouvriers et les gens qui
sont là ce sont des oies de quitter qui
gagne 450 euros at-on le droit de
dépenser autant et d'augmenter les
impôts de diminuer le pouvoir d'achat
ce n'est pas normal ce n'est pas
raisonnable donc moi je mettrai en place
un plan un plein financier qui
consistera bien sûr rembourser les
dettes sur quatre en cinq ans les
recommandations de la cour des comptes
c'est de de rembourser les dettes ont
fait le moitié jusqu'à jusqu'en 2024
eh bien nous allons peut-être aller au
delà pour soulager le portefeuille des
gens du macumba
alors on rappelle le score que vous
aviez fait lors du précédent scrutin
municipal à macouba en 2014
donc il n'y a eu qu'un premier tour
sainte rose cas qu'un l'avait emporté
avec presque 62 % des suffrages et
presque 40% vous avez fait 38 3 %
exactement des suffrages exprimés
elie wiltord borval donc vous avez
considéré que ce résultat mais aussi
d'autres résultats précédents pouvait
être encourageant pour vous qu'est ce
qui se joue lors de ces municipales 2020
cette fois pour le macumba qu'est ce qui
se joue de fondamental pour la ville et
ses habitants pour la vider ses
habitants c'est le portefeuille de ses
habitants qui vont jouer là
parce que c'est le portefeuille qui va
joué par ben et donc on constate que si
cette équipe restant classe les époux
vont augmenter ils vont pas hésiter à
augmenter les impôts moi je suis pas
pour la culture d'augmentation dépôt je
suis pour la culture de redressement de
la chasse aux gaspillages au macumba aux
dépenses inutiles si ça que je suis je
suis un bon gars vous avez expliqué ça
mais je veux dire qu'est ce qui selon
vous il ya un aménagement particulier un
équipement particulier qui devrait être
utile et nécessaire au macumba un
équipement particulier au macumba c'est
pas un équipement c'est des équipements
par exemple je vous dis le macumba est
divisée en deux il n'ya pas d'égouts
dans le bourg habitat il faut
sanitairement il faut régler ce problème
il faut régler ce problème et il y en a
d'autres problèmes des infrastructures
nous avions j'ai des projets mais je ne
veux pas les dire
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas il faut qu'on
sache
moi je dis il faut qu'on sache le
comment on règle la dette pour pouvoir
relancer les investissements
après cette période merci elie winter
borval d'avoir répondu à nos questions
et bien je vous remercie de m'avoir
invité j'espère être habilité à nouveau
à l' émission réalisée par édiles aux
curieux klervi
[Musique]